so yeah so this is first time in New
York in ages for me came in here last
week um I've been here a week I'm really
tired because well you know you get a
new city you want to explore as much as
possible so you don't go to sleep yeah
it's hi everyone so yeah so my name is
Eric elman i work at spotify you can
reach me in the information there i will
put a link to these slides in the meet
up afterwards so you can find them there
so reason i push this one closer here
because i'm going to sit here and do
some live demos as well as s so how hard
that was anyway this session i did this
one in droidcon in London it's called
it's not it's not a bug it's a feature
you know the excuse we always give as I
wrote a book we're going to give away
three of them there we said five but we
had some delivery problems we'll see how
much interest this is in the book
because I'm getting the rest of them
tomorrow yeah more on that later anyway
let's go on to this topic so this is
about bugs in the android platform it's
not bugs you write yourself this is but
bugs you find and you can't fix or
rather you can't like fix actual bug
itself but how do you work around it
anyone recognize this and one had this
moment you like there is this crash and
you google it yeah
so my job is working on the like the
platform team for the android client so
we get all of these like so I started
collecting them this is how i came up
with this presentation I'm have some of
them here so I'm gonna start with a
warm-up and as it is with bugs sometimes
a bug is just you misunderstand the
documentation or it's vaguely documented
or it's just bad wrong documentation and
sometimes it is a real real actual
buggins a platform but it's hard to know
especially with Android which is poorly
documented in many areas and a lot of
the google like just expect us to read
the source code so warm up and your
mandatory kitten picture the one thing I
discovered that was very popular
question it's likely about this one how
many of you know this method on savings
estate so anyone had problem with that
one yeah few of you okay so this is
actually because I kept getting this
question when I went out to conference I
was talking and people coming up to me I
have a weird Android but maybe you can
help me sure free consulting you go read
the documentation I'm not going to read
it out loud you can go here and read it
later and I read that one and I was like
yeah not sure what it does still really
slow text so let's do a quiz is still
the warm-up so this is the easy thing
how many of you know this when its own
savings at stake hole is it called when
you press home finish pressing back
rotating the device drop it
we haven't specified any convictions
starting a new activity oh yeah so
apparently like most developers they get
at least one of these wrong me included
so I also always go back there but now
I've written it down so now I know okay
this was a warm-up one but this is a
typical thing that like okay the
documentation is so bad that people
actually run into this bug frequently
because we really don't remember
understand the documentation and the API
itself isn't very clear on the Save
instance state yeah what does that mean
really okay the lesson here is that you
shouldn't use unsafe instance state for
anything but views because this is to
store the state of the view when the
activity is destroyed and later
recreated like rotating the device but
I've seen tons of mistakes down here
I've actually seen code where people put
the binder from a service in the bundle
for the onset instance state so yeah
don't worry if you've made some mistakes
here yourself I've seen the worst ones
okay we're moving into real real one I
have I have code for all of the demos
i'm going to show and you're going to
can find that on my github account so
you can test this yourself including
this one so i'm not going to run this
because it just crashes it's not so fun
to run something that just crashes just
going to talk about it so you have an
app widget how many he rewrites up with
yet what more okay we should write up
with it's all the time it's awesome so
this is a stack weight yet that you can
use on your home screen it's for like
for YouTube uses it i think and the
gallery apps and stuff like that can
actually click through the images you
have there so so very typical you have
the methods called get view app which
gets the view for that position in the
collection like let you have their very
simple we just set an image bitmap on
that view whenever return the remote
view 10 la done now what if we do this
you're up with yet is backed by a
content provider not very strange right
quite common you maybe we have like I
don't know a database of tracks albums
to do this in your get V you act you do
the content resolver call and you get
the input stream and you get the full
album photo there because you back that
one up in not in SQLite database but
through the content provider and you set
that image that any not one knows what
happens if you put this one on the home
screen any guess except that it will
trash well yeah sorry also the content
provider in this case that you will find
the sample code it just returns the
parcel file descriptor for that bitmap
ok so we run this you put you take the
witty to put place in your home screen
this is what you get securityexception
permission denial anyone know why sorry
you're running in the yeah exactly the
widget is running in a different process
so when it's calling your thing is
calling it over binder and then is
calling with different user ID this is
what it says that's here that actually
states the UID there and things like
that so but the problem here is that
requires a provider to be exported or
grant you write permission the problem
with this book bag here is that none of
this it states here is possible to do
you can't like use the grant you write
permission for an app widget like that
so the solution here it's the following
binder clear calling ID and then restore
calling identity two lines if you don't
use this well these two they were just
basically reset the UID that is running
in current context ER to be the one that
is in in your app instead so that's the
content provider call that you do is
valid is has a bright permission but
have to remember to restore this
otherwise you have a security problem
not documented so you need to understand
what calling identities and how the
binder works to deal with this moving on
this anyone had a problem with letter
had a broadcastreceiver and you listen
to a system broadcast install the app
but you never receive it happened like
this user person i love the user present
one it's a great great premiere
broadcast because you can kind of like
fake out to start it without the
permission yeah this start your activity
automatically when the user opens app
unlock the phone sorry anyway this won't
work and I know anyone know why it won't
work Oh apps must have been started once
before registered receiver will be
triggered also not documented okay now
we're going to do something more
advanced to say how many of you really
know how the service works but these
these of you who really understand the
service lifecycle have the service work
raise your hands and nobody dares to him
right okay sorry well so you check the
documentation that multiple clients can
connect to service at once however the
system calls your service on by method
retrieves I binder only when the first
for first client binds the system then
delivers the same binder to any
additional client that binds without
calling on behind again clear right
absolutely let's check something
so this is a I'm gonna run the app first
I'm gonna look at the code bad service
binding so what this basically does here
in every in every life cycle call back
lever have both injected in the service
connection object and in the service
itself just princess a toast in which
method was called so we see what happens
actually I will show you the code first
as well as the understand there we go so
this is this is a main activity it has
two methods for it says method for each
of the buttons so and i have the service
connection class here implementing that
one just printing out a toast in on
service connected and all service
disconnected and i can do many several
bindings basically i create a new but
new service connection option OBX this
my service clone every time i press do
bind service store that little list and
as long when i press unbind I just empty
the list just unbind it each of the
objects and really very simple demo case
for this I will see here I'm go to my
service it's very simple as a local
binder because we're running in the same
process it's know from the start and
this is where the problem is I'm going
to talk about that we have the unbind I
have the toast here I all done great
where do we toast in an Auton unbind
where I do toast and finally one start
command the first time we call on we
start the service i create the binder
here and then we have their own destroy
the binder itself doesn't do anything
because we're not doing anything about
that thing right now so let's go to
check out the app works so if i call
start service on create is called on
start come on is called nothing strange
we have a binary object that we can bind
to and I'm call bind service online cold
on service connected call nothing
stranger many of you have probably done
this before right you can unbind from
the service
and I can like keep buying several times
and notice now that only the first time
did on bind we get called the same thing
goes with now we have to wait a little
toasts disappear but yeah unbind will
should be call it well apparently didn't
anyway my point here was that we see
that there the binding work is expected
and we combined and unbiased all that
now what happens if we will have the
wrong what happens if i don't call start
service the first time so that the
service is the local binder the binder
of it here is no well let's try that the
service has been destroyed so I just
called bind service right away I get a
non create call I get to unbind call
from the service but I don't get a
non-service connected well let's expect
it it's no okay we call start service it
will create the binary object but
nothing happens so the problem here is
the problem here is let me just get back
to the code is that the unbind and on
unbind are only called once during the
life cycle of the service for each
intent that we bind with use for binding
so if the if the binder here is no
that's also the binder that the value
that gets cached by the system and there
is no way around that unless you
actually stop the service and destroy it
yeah not very well documented you have
to like really test this to yourself but
this is also something I've seen
happening several times and people have
come up and asking about it so yeah
what's up with that one
now did you notice something else here
and we're going to go back to the here
first and yeah this is also just another
example of how that could be one pop
every way is to do use messenger to to a
async communication with the service
instead through a messenger and so it
will look like that instead same problem
so the first lesson is that the binder
or being is cash bae systems you should
always create the binary orbit at
service initialization or in on crate
very very important number two is you
can pass parameters to unbind in the
intent everything but the but the data
URI and the action string is stripped
away in on bind but you can put
parameters in the data URI and that way
you can cheat you pay you pass this and
you can return different binders for
different scenarios very useful actually
if you have that kind of service design
okay now one other thing here anyone
know when own service disconnected is
called is it cold let's go back to my
demo here so I will start the service
just make short destroyed first start
from the beginning we start the service
so it's got the binder object we point
once on bind gets called once on service
connected get for I know it's a little
bit small maybe to see but on service
connected is called now if I click
unbind I should get a non service
disconnected call right that's what we
think that's the AP it looks like that
well we don't
because if you check the documentation
it actually mentioned this the brief
documentation it doesn't mention this
call when a connection to service has
been lost yeah well that's what happened
right if you go in and shake the more
deeper documentation this bindings the
service will remain active and this
typically happens when the process
hosting service has been has crashed or
being killed that's the only time the
process that you were buying into with
that crashed which means that in our
case it will never happen because we
will have a local service so yeah so the
right way to always do it is make sure
that any reference you have to the
binder object that you get from the on
service connected you should always set
to null before you do online service
just to be sure okay lesson learned here
read the Javadoc more properly i am i've
made this mistake myself a couple of
times so yeah this bug kept me awake for
two weeks and this one was really hard
define so I'm gonna demo it to you let's
see here and let's see him good let's
hope the music place now but but we
write a music player for instance you
know play music
usually leaves out and some users had a
tendency to do this because they believe
that that saves memory right now our
appt listens to the user present intenta
broadcast the colors that would not
receive the user present I'll show you
the code later huh let's look at the
code and yeah this is one and two-person
take him up oh sorry so the service in
this case is very simple here it just
has media player that plays a song when
you when we started and we can also stop
it and when you started it's it's we
also do start foreground here which puts
up the notification the typical way of
keeping in the service running in the
background after the UI have gone away
like we do for music player or many
other applications now see here let's go
to the activity activity does the same
thing here Oh varies typically it binds
now we bind a non resume and unpause you
should probably do that in on start and
stop but I don't mind I start the
service and a bind to the service and
then I have a button called for for
calling start foreground job in the
service I have a typical aidl interface
that I get here nothing strange I don't
kill my up anywhere yet whenever I do
this i miss the broadcast receiver also
to the
let's check that one
or to navigate one
so I also have a receiver here manifests
to see it again
this is what the manifest looks like
have a receiver I have the user present
because a receiver I don't do anything
special our just cleaned up nothing
weird and actually like when I wanted it
will actually printed in the toast we
were open now user would leave swipe
away that one everything keeps playing a
user logs advice user unlocks it device
and because we're interested in user
present what's happening that shouldn't
be happening and didn't matter you can
google this as much as you want there is
no nothing else ringing this until well
this is this is a process for doing this
you can you can take this code and you
can just repeat this yourself you see
will happen doesn't matter which version
of Android you go for it it's a present
in Android 5.2 as well and the way to
solve this is to use the method on task
remove which is a callback what happens
when the user swipes away a task in the
task manager in the link here is a blog
post where to describe the problem it's
a bug in the activity manager and hasn't
be fixed erase this to google talk to
Chet haze about it it was like hmm
literally so there are bugs filed on
this as well so we'll see we'll see what
happens maybe they will fix it and now
this one it's also very very difficult
so we have native library share native
library and our sort in our application
which is shared among other clients this
one happened we got find library
terminal we got an unsatisfied link era
where we tried to load the SFL the esso
file was there in the APK everything
work it should work but on a very very
low percent of the devices sometimes
they got this the SF I'll wasn't there
we had no clue
and we searched and we searched and
searched and in the chromium project for
Android we found this it's too small for
you guys to read here and I will have a
link to this code in this presentation
as well basically there is a bug and the
funniest thing here is for those of you
stick close by you see here workaround
for be 13 to 16 167 you know in
googolplex android review get corp
google chrome / ah that one yeah i try
to get information about this bug and
there is like nothing google knows it
internally and knows there is a bug so
they have a workaround they have a
library loader helper that when this
occurs they basically extract the iso
file manually copies into the private
data store and loads that one yes so
anyway now that we know this you will
note if you have a native code in your
application it happens more frequently
with large native libraries so it's
probably some timing issue I haven't
been figuring out yet but now you know
what's problem is you might have seen it
you know where to fix it you can just go
and steal this one the library load will
help with the Java from their project
just drop it into your project and use
that one and you're fine kind of weird
bug though the x86 jit bug this was
something you may run into a couple of
weeks ago really weird let me show you
here a typical photo we want to blur it
there is an algorithmic or stack blur
it's really fast works well used
everywhere so what I happens would I
just called stack blur on this one so
everything should work fine this runs
well on anything but x86 funny thing
that is this is the exception array
index out of bounds with Anna rain sighs
that doesn't really match that if
something is wrong something is totally
off with you debug this it never happens
if you put on the debugger you never run
into it the only way to get around this
is to turn on vm safe mode equals true
on x86 builds and that solves it there
is a bug in the JIT compiler for x86 at
least which indicates is there probably
are other bugs as well so i would guess
that there when you run into this there
is like this weird thing that happens it
shouldn't be a crash here we have unit
tests it runs on host that where Phi C
code is working but you still get the
crash on the device Oh try this VM safe
mode equals true in the specific case of
using stack blur on x86 well x86 devices
are pretty rare but we never know might
be more than soon similar bugs might
exist on arm so but in this case with
blur there i will say use renderscript
instead especially if you're targeting
api levels above 15 and such we have to
talk about this one as well the last one
how many of you have run into the 64 k
method limit and of course how many of
you did this because of google play
services so we all love the google play
services 6.5 they came out it has like
this modular dependency management so
you can not import need to import the
whole thing it's great if anyone here
have never heard of the 64 k method
problem oh yeah so basically it's like
the index that is used for the index
file to index each of the method
references it stores a short 16-bit what
means 64k methods references in one
single Dex file the recommendation from
google has been well split up your
project in multiple text file and load
them with a class loader instead yeah
thanks
so what what you can do what they added
a couple of months ago even I think was
a couple options for the decks tool the
tool that takes the Java classes and
compile them over to text files so multi
decks basically you split them up you
provide a list of your your main classes
that needs to be in the first one
problem probably like your main activity
and your application and then it will
just pick the other ones as it goes they
also added in the support library the
multi text application how many of you
who had a problem check has checked this
out and do you not guys know what to
type what the impact of this is so when
you're running on anything lower than
lolipop what it will do is when the
application starts up it will copy the
extra text files you have to your
internal storage on the first install or
on the update so you do an i/o operation
on the main thread at startup exactly
the thing we were told not to do well
that's the only way to do it we need we
need to some we need to load them as
soon as possible otherwise you know you
can't find the classes in your app will
crash with a like class not found
exception or whatever they made it
really simple in the latest later Gradle
plugins you just do multi Dex enabled
equal true and it will do the multi
texting for you so so it's really simple
to do with these days lessons learned
without one use proguard configure your
proguard a little bit more stop using
this huge libraries like guava and in
one use guava in the round wrap yeah you
really don't have to there are better
alternatives and write it yourself if
you have to just copy that class that
you use only use multi texts the last
resort avoid it for release builds
to rely on proguard as far as possible
like your internal debug builds I can
understand that you need to do this but
that's okay you usually run on high-end
device but users with low-end devices
all the devices suddenly going to start
loading cope with copying stuff on the
main thread you might get an anr on the
first startup and they will uninstall
your app anyone here heard of Jack and
Jill tool shame great you know what you
what that is but Jack and Eli's new to
change being developed on the a USB so
you can find it there it contains it's a
new completely new tube chain but by
passing the Java class compiled to
compile step and the decks compile step
not ready for production use yet you can
try it out but yeah I that one will
solve a lot because it will allow for
more heavier and more efficient oh yeah
obfuscation step okay conclusion about
everything of this is that Android
documentation can be taken new google
engineers are just like us they do
mistakes and a good way to do when you
get this weird bugs is go to android
xref which has indexed all the android
open source project different versions
so you can go in there and browse the
code and discover what is happening on
this specific device with a specific
android version submit bug report and
patches google actually reads every bug
report they don't ignore them as some
people who claim the code samples here
or on my github account Eric elman is my
github account so you can find them
they're the only one that's not there is
a stack blur bug the x86 eat one I have
to clean that one up little bit first
and I don't that thank you for listening
any questions
questions all right nothing